tu me croirait si je te disais que tu
m'as manqué non j'ai besoin de toi
mathiot tu es la seule personne en qui
j'ai confiance
super tu rentrais chez moi par
effraction et tu viens parler de
confiance qu'est ce que tu veux je ne
connais personne d'aussi efficace au
combat moi j'ai toutes les infos yakuza
ne sont jamais partis
c'est pas possible je les ai déjà éjecté
de new york
non c'est faux en fait il si berne et en
attendant tu neutralisent tous leurs
ennemis
maintenant la ville est nettoyé si on
s'associe du personne tu as compris
tu as faim à chaque fois que je g ses
escaliers
je me demande si je vais trouver mort
quand ton talent
il se passe des choses horribles dans
cette ville
j'en ai marre de m'excuser d'être ce que
je suis
cette ville a besoin de moi
ce n'est plus ta vie
mon système ne marche pas dit si ça ne
s'arrêtait jamais
la guerre est déclarée matures
la seule chose à faire c'est se battre
ils se sont donné un nom la main vous ne
pourrez pas stopper ce que nous avons
mis en route
le changement est proche
audi donc a pris du muscle ça me plaît
ça